[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et paléo news
l'émission qui fait des news avec du
vieux nous sommes en novembre 2021 et
l'image du jour des deux voies mais
devrais je me dire l'image du bois c'est
ce crâne voici le crâne de l'eiti de son
petit surnom les tiki et un juvénile
d'aumône allez dis donc au monal et 10
pour rappel c'est cette espèce de alors
d'homininés très similaire à homo
habilis qui a été découvert en afrique
du sud et qui avait sept ces deux
particularités devrais je dire la
première c'est d'être extrêmement jeune
aux alentours de 200 à 300 mille ans
seulement donc contemporain des tout
premiers homo sapiens
ce qui est plutôt curieux dans la mesure
où au monal et 10 à un tout petit
cerveau il a un cerveau de la dimension
comme j'ai dit il est très similaire au
mobilise donc un cerveau qui est dans
les 400 à 600 centimètres cubes faudrait
500 600 centimètres cubes donc ce qui
est vraiment homo habilis quoi
intermédiaire entre homo erectus et et
australopithèques us en termes de taille
de cerveau donc un tout petit cerveau
mais qui a vécu donc relativement
récemment en même tant qu'homo sapiens
donc ça c'est la première curiosité la
deuxième curiosité à propos de mona les
10 c'est que la première découverte
d'aumône à lady a été faite dans une
grotte qui s'appelle la grotte rising
star étoile montante en france est très
poétique et 7 et dans une chambre de
cette grotte qui s'appelle la dina lady
chamber la chambre d'inhaler dit on a
trouvé au monal et 10 mai que homo
naledi et sain c'est curieux parce que
les seul assemblage mono spécifique
c'est-à-dire ne contenant qu'une seule
espèce d'homininés qu'on connaisse à
l'heure actuelle ça porte un nom ça
s'appelle un cimetière
donc si on en croit nos observations va
les observations qui ont été faites par
l'équipe de l'iburger qui est l'équipe
qui est exclusive qui travaillent sur
mona et 10 est la seule équipe qui
travaille sur un modèle est dit l'équipe
ii l'iburger du professeur l'iburger de
l'université du witwatersrand qui est
donc un de mes collègues et bien si on
en croit cette équipe les travaux de
cette équipe les observations il ya que
au monal est dit dans cette grotte en
tout cas dans la chambre d'inhaler 10
est le seul moyen d'expliquer sa basse
et que home aumône à lady se débarrasser
de ces morts alors se débarrasser de ces
grands morts
alors deux possibilités maintenant soit
c'était pour des raisons
funéraire donc il y avait un rite
funéraire un proto rites funéraires
devrais je dire puisqu'on est quand même
on est quand même deux cent mille ans
avant le premier rite funéraire avéré un
le premier rite funéraire avérés les
premiers rites funéraires à berrer
ce sont néandertal et sapiens mais on
est quand même 150 mille deux cent mille
ans avant ça donc on pourrait parler
d'un proto rites funéraires ou alors la
deuxième raison c'est une raison non
funéraire est là on peut inventer tout
ce qu'on veut il n'aimait pas les morts
en europe dont qu'il les balance est
raisons sanitaires peut-être que ces
morts étaient malades de quelque chose
et que les homos naledi croyais que ça
allait mieux se débarrasser des cadavres
on sait pas on ne sait pas donc mais
bref raison rituel mais non funéraire ça
pourrait être aussi un raison rituel non
funéraire
on ne sait pas donc bref en tout cas
voilà la première découverte de monnaie
les dix c'était ça
donc hominidés à petit cerveau mais avec
mead un âge relativement jeune
contemporain de saint piat ce donc
plutôt surprenant pour un truc qui
ressemble à un homo habilis et qui
apparemment se débarrasser de ces morts
mais on ne sait pas vraiment pourquoi et
donc cette année on nous annonce enfin
juste là il ya quelques jours quand
j'enregistre cette vidéo on nous annonce
la découverte de ce petit crâne donc ce
petit crâne très partiel dano mona lady
juvénile juvénile limite bébé ils ont
estimé d'après l'anatomie des dents
voyez qu'il ya des dents de lait des
très jolies d'anglais qui sont
représentés comme si elle était à la
surface mais elle n'était pas à la
surface évidemment quand il était vivant
mais là pour les montrer en les
représentations face donc des petites
d'anglais qui sont ici représentée là et
donc à l'anatomie des dents de lait et à
la séquence d'éruption des dents de lait
on peut dire que le truc avait entre 4
et 6 ans quand il est mort voilà donc
donc je sais pas un bébé mais ça je vais
ni le très très jeune quoi c'est à peu
près le même âge d'ailleurs que l'enfant
de tang si vous vous rappelez de ce
qu'est l'enfant de tanks d'ailleurs je
crois je pense ne pas me tromper en me
disant que le socle en noir alors ici ce
que vous voyez ce n'est pas le crâne
entier en fait c'est il ya un socle en
noir sur lequel ils ont posé les
morceaux qui ont été découverts et qui
sont représentés en couleurs ici donc on
a un petit bout du chemin des petits
bouts la du crâne fin du sommet du crâne
de la boîte crânienne on a le sommet des
orbites ici et puis on a les dents
quelques dents en tout cas pas tout mais
quelques-unes
donc et là je pense en fait qu'ils ont
utilisés comme socle un moulage de
l'enfant de tang ça me paraît
raisonnable de faire cette hypothèse
parce que ça ressemble vraiment vous
voyez le découpage c'est c'est la phase
de l'enfant de tang je pense qu'ils ont
utilisés mais bref tout ça pour dire que
c'est une découverte relativement rare
c'est assez rare de découvrir des
juvéniles tout simplement parce que les
juvéniles ébahis l'aller les sutures du
crâne sont pas finis vous avez les
structures mais topic et tout ça qu'ils
sont encore cartilagineuse donc les
crânes de juvéniles ils ont tendance à
faire quand il quand le juvénile meurent
les délits crâne et ont tendance à se
décomposer complètement les dents sont
beaucoup moins minéralisée chez les
juvéniles donc elles ont tendance à se
dissoudre plus vite bref donc c'est
assez rare de découvrir des juvéniles et
là en fait ce qu'il ya d'exceptionnel
avec 7,7 au monal eddy juvénile et je
vais vous montrer la publication
maintenant donc voici la publication
publiée dans le journal
paléoanthropologie qui est un nouveau
journal open access donc en plus
libéraux guerre ne refait le coup de
relancer un nouveau journal open access
la dernière fois il avait fait ça avec
life is life qui est devenu un journal
tout à fait respectable depuis hier mais
voilà c'était pour le lancement de il ay
fils il avait aussi lancé au monal et
dix bombes à la il avait aussi annoncé
au monal et 10 n'ont pas de lancer au
monal est dit faut pas lancer les
fossiles c'est pas bien donc ils ont
lancé le journal est annoncée au monal
est dit et là c'est pareil en fait ils
ont lancé le journal paléoanthropologie
un nouveau jour journal open access
c'est à dire gratuit vous pouvez y
accéder gratuitement même si vous n'êtes
pas abonné
et donc ils ont annoncé la découverte de
ce je vais nulle pour faire de la
publicité au journal an donc donc je
respecte abelin comme comme démarche
donc c'est l'équipe de l'iburger qui a
publié sa est donc là là où ça devient
intéressant en fait c'est que ils ont
découvert ce nouveau ce nouveau petit
fossiles vous avez la chambre d'inhaler
10 est en fait ils l'ont découvert dans
la chambre et ce qu'ils appellent la
chambre du chaos on voyait la surface et
là là vous avez tous les passages hyper
compliqué qu'il fallait passer pour
arriver à la chambre d'inhaler dit hélas
ce petit crâne il vient de la chambre du
chaos qui est encore plus loin que la
chambre d'inhaler dit encore plus
inaccessible
et ça ça c'est intéressant parce que du
coup ça relance la question mais vous
voyez les dents là les magnifiques dans
donc sa relance la question de comment
est-ce que ces fossiles sont arrivés là
bah oui parce que déjà il ya la question
de pourquoi dans la chambre d'inhaler
dire on a que aumône aller dit il existe
d'autres chambres dans le système rising
star
il ya d'autres chambres comme la chambre
laisser 10 où on retrouve au monal et 10
mai avec une faune associée donc il ya
de la faune avec avec le au monal est
dit dans la chambre et s'est dit c'est
ce qu'ils avaient annoncé en 2010 est
donc ça c'est pas compliqué à
interpréter je veux dire il suffit d'un
trou et les trucs tombe dedans mais là
dans la chambre d'inhaler dit non
seulement il n'y a pas de trou évident
pour y accéder faux pas c'est vraiment
par des petits passages très très étroit
etc mais en plus en plus de passer par
tous ces petits passages étroits et bien
la chambre kaos aller encore plus loin
que la chambre d'inhaler dit encore plus
inaccessible et la easy ont découvert
donc ce petit crâne alors dans la
publication il ya rien s'est pas
présenté joliment voyez les dents sont
présentés individuellement etc après il
ya toutes les comparaisons etc mais
voilà le sait c'est un c'est un truc b
c'est bizarre comment sais tu comment
ces fossiles finissent là voyez c'est le
petit bout de leurs beats ici
comment ces fossiles sont ils arrivés là
alors l'iburger dans son annonce a
développé le fait que le crâne était
tout seul y'a rien d'autre que le crâne
dans cette chambre sur le site de dépôt
du du petit du petit lait ti donc le
crâne était tout seul et pour lui c'est
évidemment ça c'est là l'idée qu'il
défend c'est pour lui c'est évidemment
un signe que le crâne a été déposé là
une fois qu'il était déjà sous forme de
crâne
donc pour lui le crâne a été déposée
dans la chambre du chaos
quand il était déjà en fait la chair
était déjà parti quoi donc le crâne a
été déposée intentionnellement par les
homos naledi à cet endroit tout au fond
de la grotte ce qui à plusieurs
applications encore une fois
l'application du rite funéraire
parce que vouloir aller tout au fond
d'une grotte comme ça enfin je veux dire
les choses les plus stupides se font pas
au hasard là c'est vraiment une action
extrêmement stupide de vouloir aller au
plus profond d'une grotte pour aller
déposer un crâne donc ces choses
stupides ne se font pas par hasard elles
se font avec motivation et la motivation
la seule motivation qu'on arrive à se
représenter nous en tant qu'humain
moderne c'est la religion la croyance le
rite funéraire
bref y'a pas de religion à l'époque
évidemment mais je dis enfin en tout cas
rien que nous qualifierions de religion
mais bref c'est le rite funéraire quoi
le respect aux morts donc pour lui ça
pour lui le dépôt de ce crâne tout seul
comme ça ça voudrait dire que que le
crâne a été déposée intentionnellement
et donc ce n'était pas juste au monal ai
dit qu'ils se débarrasser de ses mac
abeilles quoi c'était vraiment aumône
heidi qui déposait ses morts ses petits
mort
qui enterrait ses petits morts
dans les deux façons ritualisé
j'avoue que je suis un peu perplexe
parce que si à chaque fois que c'est à
dire on est encore une fois on est en
contexte humain on est en contexte
d'évolution humaine mais si on trouvait
nous
paléontologues des vertébrés facile à
chaque fois qu'on trouvait un crâne tout
seul comme ça on devait se dire qu'il
avait hérité une erreur j'avoue que
dicte aux dons
directs aux dons serait vraiment pas mal
dans la catégorie rites funéraires donc
non enfin bref je suis perplexe et je
suis pas le seul de toute façon je vais
bien mais mais en tout cas c'est
intéressant on peut pas on peut pas
négliger que c'est intéressant je veux
dire comment ces fossiles sont arrivés
jusque là par contre ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant un autre truc qui à
l'intéressant justement dans la réponse
à cette question c'est que
accompagnant l'annoncé de la découverte
donc de ceux du petit lait ti jeu
juvénile d'un modèle est dit il y a
aussi un article qui parle donc de la
taphonomie et dans cet article sur la
taphonomie de la grotte rising star il
est mentionné l'existence de faux cils
de babouins il ya des fossiles de
babouins dans la grotte rising star et
ça c'est intéressant ça veut dire que
tout
toute intention qui auraient pu être
mises dans le dépôt des ossements de
mona lady il existe quand même des
circonstances qui peuvent amener des
ossements d'autres animaux dans cette
même note
ces circonstances existe après c'est pas
pour faut pas me faire dire ce que j'ai
pas dis hein attention faut pas me faire
dire ce que j'ai pas dit j'ai pas dis ah
bah c'est bon il ya un crâne de babouins
donc ça fout tout en l'air c'est pas un
dépôt intentionnelle non non j'ai pas
dit ça j'ai dit il ya du reste de
babouins
d'ailleurs ça il ya du reste de babouins
mais ils disent ce qu'ils vont en papier
aux spécimens donc ceux qui rentrent
papineau spécimens ça veut dire qu'il ya
que un spécimen de babouins
avec un spécimen de babouins donc il
faut pas non plus faut pas non plus
surévaluer l'importance de ce spécimen
mais il est bien clair que je ne dis pas
que parce qu'il ya un babouin alors ça
veut dire que tous les restes de mona
les dix sont arrivés au fond de la
grotte
naturellement ça naturellement non de
façon non d'entropic
ce que je veux dire c'est que il ya des
phénomènes qui peuvent amener
naturellement des restes de vertébrés au
fond de cette droite voilà
mais il ya quand même beaucoup plus je
veux dire rappelez vous il ya quand même
plus de 15000 restes d'homo naledi dans
le rien que dans la chambre d'inhaler 10
à 15000 aux semences et 15000 ossements
ils sont pas tous arrivés là de la même
façon que un morceau de babouins voyez
c'est ça que je veux dire donc il faut
pas surévaluer non plus l'importance de
ce babouins mais il existe des
phénomènes naturels qui peuvent
expliquer au moins en partie le dépôt de
ces homos na li dit on verra le futur
nous le dira mais
les voilà il faut faire confiance à
l'équipe de l'iburger ils ont quand même
été assez consistants dans l' annonce de
nouvelles découvertes ils ont toujours
été très transparent ils ont toujours
postés leur découverte sur morpho
sources donc et à chaque fois sur des
journaux open access donc à chaque fois
toutes leurs données sont accessibles ce
qui est quand même remarquable en
paléoanthropologie en paléoanthropologie
les gens ont plutôt tendance à être
protecteur on va dire
plutôt qu'à être open access donc voilà
il s'est quand même à leur crédit de
vouloir rester absolument transparent et
on verra du coup quelles seront les
découvertes dans le futur c'est mais
c'est intéressant c'est intéressant un
petit spécimens juvéniles retrouvait là
comme ça tout seul au plus profond de la
grotte donc ça implique et ouais j'ai
commencé un truc tout à l'heure donc ça
applique possible aux rites funéraires
la deuxième chose que cela implique et
qui est intéressant c'est que ça
implique l'utilisation du feu parce
qu'ils sont pas allés là-bas à tâtons
n'allait au monal et 10,6 y sont allés 1
quand une fois ci on parle pas d'un
dépôt d'origine naturelle ou une entrée
qui qu'on n'aurait pas encore repéré ou
quoi que ce soit ça veut dire aussi aux
utilisations du feu bon on attend encore
l'annoncent de charbon de bois qui
auraient été découverts dans l'est dans
la grotte rising star ça n'a pas encore
été annoncé mais on verra dans le futur
ils ont parlé il ya des bruits de
couloirs qui parle de charbon il ya des
bruits de couloirs qui parle beauty mais
ce ne sont que des bruits de couloir
pour l'instant
voilà donc ça c'était pour homo naledi
la grande annonce sur mona et dès la
deuxième annonce
c'est c'est celle de au mob oddo and cie
ce qui a été annoncé dans le journal
evolutionnary anthropologie il y a
quelques semaines et que vous avez
certainement vu passer dans votre fil
d'actualité sous la forme une nouvelle
espèce d'ancêtres d'humains
[Rires]
la classique j'ai envie de dire le grand
classique une nouvelle espèce dans cette
rue main réécrit l'arbre évolutif
réécrit l'évolution humaine toujours pas
absolument toujours pas donc pour ceux
qui me suivent sur facebook et sur
twitter je me suis un peu énervé donc je
vais essayer un petit peu nuancé mon
propos ce coup là mais ça m'a un peu
énervé cette annonce parce que aux mobo
de n 6 s'est pas du tout une nouvelle
découverte d'une part 2 et 2,2 ça ne
réécris absolument rien donc ça m'a
vraiment vraiment énervé vous voyez là
déjà jeu je commence à avoir des tacles
ça me met les nerfs en pelote ce genre
d'effets d'annoncé
et oui donc aux mobo de m6 donc qui est
en fait les auteurs de cet article 10
que ben on à homo rhodésienne si son
know mots qu'est ce que c'est l'autre et
d'albert guen s'ils sont à plat une
prolifération d'espèces du genre homo
dans le pléistocène qui ont tout à un
moment ou à un autre était proposée
comme étant des ancêtres d'homo sapiens
de ce qu'il propose c'est de prendre
tout ce beau monde de le réunir dans une
seule espèce et de l'appeler aux mobo de
m6 en référence au crâne de bodo qui
nous vient d'afrique de l'est et qui est
classiquement considéré comme un homo
sapiens arkalyk donc on met tout ça dans
homobono 26 et on annonce fièrement
conte à l'ancêtre d'homo sapiens ce qui
dans l'absolu n'est pas complètement
faux puisque si on met tout le monde
ensemble la probabilité qu'il ya un an
c'est être quelque part
ça ça se défend surtout comme je les dis
aux mobo de m6 est classiquement
considéré comme un homo sapiens
archaïque
mais
comment dire il ya tellement de
problèmes il ya tellement de problèmes
dans ce concept là il ya tellement de le
premier problème déjà donc voici le
crâne voici un crâne de bodo le crâne de
vo2 d'ailleurs baudot un don qui est un
joli crâne je vais dire et qui est
considéré comme lolo type de homobono 26
le prof le problème en fait avec cette
démarche c'est qu'il crée une nouvelle
espèce à partir d'une vieille découverte
parce que le crâne de bodo il a été
découvert dans les années soixante dix
il a déjà été décrit il a déjà été
poncés en long en large et en travers le
crâne de bodo donc il ya déjà ça ensuite
le deuxième problème qui a avec donc
c'est pas nouveau voilà là où je veux en
venir c'est que aux bobos de m6 et c'est
loin d'être quelque chose de nouveau en
réalité c'est une vieille idée de placer
l'homme de bodo comme ancêtre d'homo
sapiens de 2
2 2 le problème avec définir une
nouvelle espèce homo beau domaine sis
en comme ça en la décrivant comme étant
forcément l'ancêtre d'homo sapiens ben
vous créer ce qu'on appelle un taxon par
affi l'éthique et en un mot comme en
cent vous créez un trucs merdiques
parce que vous avez un ancêtre en commun
qui n'est pas l'ancêtre de tous ses
descendants du coup pas vous avez un
ancêtre en commun à l'espèce homo beau
de n 6 mai au mob de m6 en fait ne
contient pas les descendants de tous et
ans tous les descendants de cet ancêtre
en commun dont vous créez une espèce
bâtarde en gros c'est vraiment une
espèce bâtarde et ça va poser problème
un jour voilà ça va forcément poser
problème un jour de créer une espèce qui
est par affi et excès salle points c'est
une définition problématique si vous
voulez pas vous encombrer de je veux pas
vous encombrer de trop de jargon donc
c'est pas la peine de retenir par hafid
éthique je veux dire si vous êtes
familier avec le mot tant mieux mais si
vous n'êtes pas familier avec le mot
retenez simplement que définir une
espèce comme étant de base l'ancêtre
d'une autre espèce ça veut dire que
cette espèce en gros est mal défini une
espèce doit compte il doit contenir un
ancêtre en commun est le descendant de
tout cet ancêtre en commun et ce n'est
pas le cas dans robot de m6 puisque par
définition ne contient aussi aux mots
sinclair
donc c'est un problème c'est un énorme
problème et ça ça veut dire qu'à un jour
fatalement quelqu'un reviendra sur la
définition de mogo de n 6 et la pointera
du doigt en disant ça ça marche pas ça
ça peut pas marcher donc pourquoi le
faire maintenant alors qu'on le sait
déjà ça va poser problème un jour donc
ça c'est le deuxième gros problème le
troisième gros problème avec hobo de n 6
bat c'est qu'il essaye de mettre
ensemble et d'albert gagnent 6
rhodésienne si c'est tout un tas d
espèces du genre homo qui avaient été
définis auparavant et le problème c'est
que toutes ces espèces la hesse elle ne
forment pas un groupe cohérent donc
voilà je suis allé vous recherchez un
article que j'avais dont j'avais parlé
dans un précédent paléo news dont celui
qui décrivait l'homme dragon moulongui
est donc dans cet homme draps dans la
fugue dans le cet article sur l'homme
dragon il y avait une file au génie de
tous les homos du pléistocène donc eux
ils ont fait le travail de faire une
phylogénie de construire un cloud au g
basée sur des données qui sont
observables et répétable alors avec tout
le avec tous les défauts qu'on peut lui
trouver à cette phylogénie puisqu'elle
en a deux il n'y a pas de fil au génie
sans défaut 1 mais avec tous les défauts
qu'on peut lui trouver avec cette fille
le génie à la au moins l'avantagé d'être
basée sur quelque chose de concret sur
une matrice de caractère des données qui
sont répétable voilà observe observables
et répétable à volonté et donc les
crânes de bodo donc là vous avez homo
sapiens
là vous avez homologué là vous avez
néandertal et là vous avez et d'albert
gagnent 6 plus beau dos voilà là il se
trouve là le crâne de bodo et vous voyez
que le crâne de bodo il se trouve
effectivement formé un cloud avec
rhodésienne 6
mai par contre ils forment pas du tout
un club avec ici mawer la mandibule de
mawer qui est de bergues n 6 qui est le
lot type de heidelberg n 6 et là vous
avez notre fameux hunt de tautavel voilà
qui est dans canal de bergues n 6
d'après cette phylogénie est donc là ce
que vous avez c'est que vous avez le
fameux ensemble par raffi l'éthique et
d'albert gagnent 6 rhodésienne 6 donc
l'ensemble paraphilie ticket de le père
jan 6 2e 6 il est là et il est déjà
identifiée ici comme étant par un fil
éthiques pourquoi pourquoi mettre tout
ça ensemble
et donc former un truc qui va être de
toute façon comme je les dis
problématique un jour
et surtout regarder homo sapiens est là
et votre beau de n 6 il est là donc même
en admettant que tout ce beau monde
forment un jour un ensemble monofil
éthique dans une file au génie du futur
ben on est encore une bonne distance
voyez de homo sapiens 1 on n'est pas du
tout à côté d' homo sapiens entre homo
sapiens et lui il y a homologué alors
homologué qui est peut-être un denisot
va peut-être pas vous avez néandertal
vous avez encore ce ces deux clad là le
crâne de doute ou et ses autres crânes
qui sont pareils c'est classiquement
considérer adelberg n 6
archaïque était archaïque homo sapiens
rhodésienne 6 tout ça tout ça c'est
complètement confondues je veux dire
c'est dû mélanger mais voilà c'est c'est
non non au mob oddo and cie sono
bordeaux annecy c'est déjà une mauvaise
idée mais en plus dire qu'ils les
ancêtres de vossa pias c'est une idée
encore pire qui est basé sur du rien je
veux qu'on va regarder ça c'est la belle
fille le génie scientifique
regardez la phylogénie qui nous donne la
voilà
qui fait encore ça ono baudot n 6 ou et
voyez c'est ça que je veux dire par on
peut lui reprocher tout ce qu'on veut à
cette phylogénie chinoise là que je vais
vous montrer de chercheurs chinois on
peut lui reprocher tout ce qu'on veut
elle aura toujours l'avantagé d'être un
élément répétable lassé de l'opinion pur
et dur voyez il n'y a rien il n'y a pas
de
n'y a pas de science là dedans ça c'est
un dessin fait sous paint à partir d'un
doigt comme ça peut poser dans le vent
deux des opinions préétabli et puis ben
voilà et alors là là où on voit
immédiatement le problème avec cette
avec cette hypothèse phylogénétique qui
nous propose là de mettre tout ensemble
et de le berghain 6 et ses bas et
dahlberg n 6 qui est classiquement
considéré comme étant l'ancêtre de
mertert à l'étang le pré néandertaliens
par excellence bas maintenant ici on a
une branche vide voilà bah une branche
qui a pas de mains
donc ils ont juste repris en fait ils
ont juste repris la
l'hypothèse phylogénétique
l'opinion j'ai envie de dire c'est même
pas une hypothèse c'est sait rien du
tout c'est qui fait encore ça en 2021 on
est en 2021 il ya encore des gens qui
dessine des petits nuages comme ça dans
des publications scientifiques je veux
dire pas dans des articles pour la
presse ou ou pour l'éducation des
enfants nan nan là on est dans une
publication scientifique à comité de
lecture et encore des gens qui décident
des petits nuages comme ça c'est c'est
affolant et c'est d'autant plus
impardonnable c'est d'autant plus
impardonnable que quelques semaines
avant santé 5 août ça c'est une
hypothèse sur laquelle on peut
travailler là y'a de la science là il y
en a point sari en a pas donc bref
et donc voilà tout ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est remplacer archaïque homo sapiens
donc homo sapiens anatomiquement
archaïque par aux mobo de m6 c'est tout
ce qu'ils ont fait et c'est non c'est un
c'est un grand nom pour moi et je pense
je pense et j'espère que ça ne fera pas
date parce que vraiment je trouve ça
extrêmement problématique non seulement
de proposer des taxons qui sont
ouvertement par affi l'éthique
des proposer des descriptions de taxes
ans qui sont ouvertement par affi
l'éthique les soutenir par des hypothèse
phylogénétique qui ne sont que des
opinions voilà qui ne sont basées que
sur des opinions alors c'est des
opinions d'experts tant mieux tant pis
mais ça reste des opinions c'est
absolument pas tes stable contrairement
à ça ça ça c'est des hypothèses ça on
peut revenir à la matrice d'origine il
ya une matrice de caractère derrière ça
qui a été analysé de façon statistique
on peut revenir à cette matrice de
caractère et changer le codage de la
matrice en fonction des les observations
futur ou des opinions justement et on
peut tester la validité de ses opinions
grâce à ça en faisant retourner une
analyse avec façon différente d'observer
les caractères ça c'est possible ça
c'est ça par contre on peut pas
travailler dessus
les petites filles le génie en nuage là
comme ça c'est impossible de travailler
donc donc ce sera un grand nombre
j'espère que aux mobo de m6 sera oublié
parce que vraiment c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose qui devrait exister de
toute façon d'après le code de
nomenclature
zoologique ont fait pas des espèces par
affi l'éthique parce que si homobono n 6
et une est considéré comme une espèce
valide alors par définition tous ses
descendants devrait être considéré comme
good aux mobo de m6 ce qui inclut homo
sapiens or homo sapiens préexiste à aux
mobo de m6 donc aux mobo de m6 est en
fête homo sapiens voile
si vraiment vous voulez jouez vous
voulez foncé à fond dans le jeu de la
nomenclature taxonomique
ya un moyen tout simple ces voix là homo
sapiens est un est un binôme qui a
existé avant beau de m6 ils ont la même
description aux mobo de m6 est homo
sapiens fin de l'histoire mais de toute
façon il ya plein d'autres problèmes au
niveau de ton nomenclature taxonomique
puisque aux mobo de n 6 s'est déjà 1,1
retravaille de deux espèces qui existe
déjà et d'albert gagnent 6 et
rhodésienne 6 donc en fait en réalité il
faudrait plutôt prendre le plus vieux
des deux à savoir et de berriane 6 en
fait aux mobo de m6 devrait être aidé
halberg n 6 voilà si on devait vraiment
enfin une autre façon d'aborder le
problème c'est que dalle berg m6 devrait
être homo de m6 devrait en fait être et
de bergen 6 maidenberg n 6 après il ya
d'autres hypothèses qui en font au mot
l'homme de néandertal ce qui n'est pas
l'hypothèse défendue il l'a d'ailleurs
je le rappelle
ici il n'y a pas de pré néandertaliens
curieusement mais bref
voyez s'est plaint de problèmes s'est
plaint de problèmes et je pourrais
passer des jours entiers à vous en faire
la liste aux mobo de m6 c'est un grand
nom et je pense et j'espère que que ça
restera un grand nom et que cette
nomenclature ne sera pas accepté parce
que elle pose plus de papa parce que je
n'aime pas ou peu ce que j'ai l'air
c'est parce qu'elle pose plus de
problèmes qu'elle n'en résout d'ailleurs
elle ne résout aucun problème mais elle
pose beaucoup d'autres problèmes autre
autre truc à eux qui m'a un peu
c'est même pas l'article en lui même qui
m'a fait dresser les poils c'est plutôt
encore une fois la façon dont ça a été
vendu dans la presse
donc autre annonce on va dire ça a été
l'annoncé bas qu'on a un homme bipèdes
le premier homme bipèdes en europe mais
le retour de l'hypothèse européenne
voilà où la bipédie est né en europe at
on pu lire ici et là bon bah ça vient
d'un article paru dans scientifique
report qui est donc encore une fois
encore et toujours dans cette fameuse
succursale de nature's est donc dans
scientific report on nous annonce donc
une nouvelle datation des empreintes de
crète alors les empreintes de crète ce
sont les ce sont les fameuses empreinte
bipèdes datée d'environ 6 millions
d'années 5e 5,7 millions d'années dont
on n'ose dont il était question dans un
reportage que j'ai des bunkers et
ensuite j'ai géré des bugs et ça j'ai
des bonnes qui est certainement deux
fois en fait que ça commence à devenir
agaçant dans par les
cetc les empreintes des genres d'emprunt
de bipèdes pas très très jolie
d'ailleurs c'est une petite piste et
donc effectivement ça ressemble comme si
un singe avait marché sur deux pattes je
pense qu'il doit y avoir une photo ce
sera plus parlant que que d'essayer
d'écrire mais n'ont même pas ils ont
même pas remis de photos bref quelque
part en crète il y a une piste
d'empreintes qui datent de 5,7 millions
d'années et qui donc semblent avoir été
faites par des loyers des débats avec
des pouces opposables voilà et donc est
donc cette nouvelle ce nouvel article
qui est fait par la même équipe que
celle qui avait clamé l'origine
européenne des êtres humains c'est
madeleine c'est l'équipe de madeleine
beau même si vous avez vu le reportage
ou mon bébé en cash de ce reportage vous
savez qui c'est
donc cette même équipe maintenant hard
hat et les empreintes de crête est donc
maintenant elle non plus 5,7 elles ont
six millions d'années
6,2 et 6 millions d'années voilà ce qui
change pas grand chose à l'histoire on
est bien d'accord
ça les rend à peu près aussi vieille que
horohorine voilà
et puis c'est tout
ça les rend à peu près aussi viennent
corps aurait aussi vieille que rory noro
rinne était bipède est salée et elles
sont toujours plus jeune que ça elle
entre aux puces alors je sais que ça
elle entre au plus il ya eu contestation
on en a parlé dans un palais aux news
précédent donc il ya eu contestation sur
le fait qu'il ait pu être bipèdes ou pas
à la il ya deux articles qui était sorti
en même temps un article qui disait
qu'il était bipède et l'autre article
qui disait qu'il n'était pas basé sur le
fémur quoique cela il veut enfin je veux
dire basé sur le fémur de toumaï bref
j'en ai parlé dans une autre vidéo donc
ça c'est pareil je vais vous mettre tous
les liens dans la description les
déblocages la vidéo sur celle entre opus
le fait est que ça elle entre aux puces
est un hominidé
enfin est à nos mini ni pardon il est de
toute façon a nommé une idée je n'ai
aucune idée ça inclut les gorilles et
chimpanzés
sallèles entre opus est un homme et nini
qu'on
considère qu'il soit bipèdes ou pas
puisque la condition de mini de sa haine
entre opus ne dépend pas que de sa
bipédie ya d'autres caractères qui
soutiennent qu'ils les bipèdes et toutes
les analyse phylogénétique tous les gens
qui ont pris le temps de faire une
analyse phylogénétique de sahel entre
opus enfin incluant sahelanthropus ont
trouvé que ça l entreprise faisait
partie des homininés 1 c'est à dire que
tant que c'est pas des temps que c'est
pas des opinions qui sont exprimés tous
les gens qui ont pris la peine de faire
plus qu exprimer une opinion on va dire
qu'ils ont pris le temps de la formule
est sous la forme d'une analyse
phylogénétique ont trouvé sa haine entre
opus comme groupe frère du reste des
homininés donc pour l'instant il n'y a
rien qui questionne sérieusement la
position de style entre opus en temps
comme unis et donc ses empreintes de
crête sont plus jeunes que celles entre
eux plus donc il ya toujours pas de quoi
remettre en question l'origine
européenne des êtres humains l'origine
humaine de l'origine européenne de la
bipédie après de toute façon la bipédie
on sait qu'elle a évolué plusieurs fois
au sein des zones minées id et là je
prends vraiment les hominoïdes c'est à
dire les grands singes on sait que la
bipédie a évolué plusieurs fois au sein
des hominoïdes vous avez les chimpanzés
qui sont capables d' une bipédie une
bipédie temporaire qui donc a un truc
comme un chimpanzé peut avoir laissé les
empreintes comme les empreintes de crète
le dire sur une courte distance marcher
sur deux pattes et ça laisse des
empreintes dans le sable pouf vous avez
votre piste concrète donc ça ça va ça
marche on sait qu en europe à cette
époque là vivait des hominoïdes
supposément bipèdes on a je crois en
l'amour à noter qu saurait au pit
écusson à danubius bref au mieux scène
il y avait des hominoïdes supposé
bipèdes mais non humains voilà donc on
sait que la bipédie a évolué plusieurs
fois donc je ne conteste pas l'âge de
toute façon je suis pas je suis pas je
suis pas un expert en datation donc je
ne conteste je ne conteste pas l'âge je
ne conteste même plus que ça a été fait
par un sage bipèdes il ya une époque où
je regardais les empreintes et je me
disais ça ressemble quand même vachement
à rien je ne conteste même pas que ça a
été fait par un singe bipèdes par contre
par contre il n'ya pas que les voilà ça
veut pas forcément dire que c'était un
ami nano min ça aurait pu être n'importe
quel hominoïdes c'est un peu le problème
avec les empreintes c'est qu'elles sont
très difficiles à identifier quoi mais
bref en tout cas moi ce que je conteste
surtout c'est la façon dont ça a été
vendu qu'à l'origine de la bipédie en
europe
[Rires]
faut voir que l'europe au mieux aux
scènes ça a été le grand centre de
diversité des hominoïdes donc le grand
centre des diversités les grands singes
dont il ya eu beaucoup
d'expérimentations évolutive alors
l'expérimentation évolutive je suis il
n'y a pas d'intention derrière donc avec
des guillemets quand même mais mais
voilà ça a été un grand centre
d'expérimentation évolutive il ya plein
de trucs qui ont été tentées dans le
milieu scènes d'europe au niveau des
grands singes dont la bipédie et comme
je les dis même certainement plusieurs
fois certainement plusieurs fois au
moins chez danube vieux c aurait opté
cus la curiosité cus a été légérement
contesté récemment
et certainement houran au pit et qu
sourd à noter qu'us qui s'il devait y
avoir un jour une origine européenne de
l'ue vanité ou à noter que je serai
certainement meilleur candidat et pas
gréco pitt et cus mais ça je vous
renvoie mon déballage
donc je vous mettrais j'essayerai d'y
penser au moment de plonger la vidéo si
j ai pas pensé petit commentaire voilà
vous mettre les débats en cage et vous
mettre les et vous mettre la vidéo sur
silent rochus voilà donc fait ni penser
si vous si vous ne la voyez pas dans si
vous ne les voyez pas dans la
description faite ni pensée gelé
rajouterai dans la description
maintenant ça c'était les et les grandes
annonces sur les hominidés on passe
maintenant à la deuxième chose
importante qui s'est produite pendant ce
mois d'octobre ce dernier mois d'octobre
nous sommes début novembre a gelé dit
tout à l'heure
donc en ce mois d'octobre 2021 il y a eu
le lancement de la du grand meeting de
la société de paléontologie des
vertébrés alors qui officiellement a eu
lieu du 1er au 5 novembre mais qui
officieusement a démarré bien avant
puisque tout est en ligne donc de toute
façon ils vont laisser ça je crois qu'on
est dans un mois ça a commencé le 20
octobre et ils vont laisser ça pendant
un mois le temps que les gens aient le
puisse regarder tous les posters puisse
regarder tous les talk etc alors ça
manque un peu d'interactivité 1
évidemment tout est en ligne qu'aux
vidéo oblige
l'année prochaine si on a de la chance
ce sera de nouveau un meeting en vrai ça
de nouveau avoir héritable congrès mais
là de tout le congrès étant digne donc
voici la page d'accueil que je voulais à
titre à titre purement
purement informatif parce que je vais
pas me mettre à aller patauger là dedans
j'ai eu du mal
n'imaginez même pas j'ai eu du mal à
naviguer là dedans mais bref à retrouver
mon propre talk parce que j'ai fait un
talk pour cette même juste retrouver mon
propre rôle que j'ai galéré donc je ne
vais pas aller là dedans
voilà je suis vieux je suis
geffroy nique bref mais voilà vous faire
un petit résumé des tôles que les plus
intéressants alors le truc c'est que
comme tout est en ligne les choses
intéressantes n'ont pas eu lieu parce
qu'évidemment les gens qui ont des
grandes choses a annoncé ne veulent pas
faire ça dans un petit un petit speech
en ligne qui sera oubliée de tous donc
ya pas eu vraiment de grosse grosse
grosse annonce faite à ce meeting la
société de paléontologie des vertébrés
les mêlées le meilleur je pense ça a été
super aux russes il ya eu un talk sur
super au russe où il expliquait qu'il
avait retrouvé du matériel en plus de la
carrière originale de super aux russes
et que du coup ils ont une
reconstruction qui est un peu plus
précise qu'ils ont pu le mesurer à 39
mètres de long ce que distille fait de
luttes ceux qui distillent fait de lui
le plus long de tous les sauropodes en
tout cas le plus long des sauropodes
pour lesquelles on a un squelette
décemment complet je suppose
puisque évidemment il y aura toujours
quelqu'un pour clamer qu'il a la plus
longue
ensuite il y a eu un talk assez
intéressant mais ça c'est mon petit
billet sud africain pour pour les
dinosaures sud-africain donc il ya eu un
talk sur une très basse au russe qui est
le premier dinosaure avec un nom
d'origine ici comme ça vous noterez que
je fais un gros effort pour faire le
clic mais c'est probablement pas le bon
clique de toute façon et ça vient
probablement aussi de faire saturer le
micro mais bref un bateau russe c'est un
il ya une nouvelle étude en fait de ceux
de ce dinosaure basé sur un scan qui a
été fait au synchrotron de grenoble est
ce un bateau russe apparemment ce serait
un ornithologue aux orres ce qui en
ferait si je ne m'abuse le premier
ornitho mimose or raisonnablement
complet d'afrique pour ne pas dire le
premier tour mais bon je ne connais pas
tous les regards ton qui ont été
découverts en afrique donc on va juste
se dire on va juste dire que c'est le
premier ornitho mimose or
raisonnablement complet d'afrique
puisque le squelette est quasiment
complet et ça en fait aussi
et ça en fait aussi oui le bateau russe
il avait aussi apparemment un crâne donc
ils ont un crâne complet et ce crâne
complet il a
il a la particularité d'avoir des toutes
petites dents très fine un petit peu
comme terreau dos trop peut-être au dos
trop ou comme les ou plutôt des petits
d'antiques ou comme un peu comme les
petits denticules des canards c'est à
dire des animaux qui filtre en fait des
animaux filtreurs de dos donc
apparemment en plus basse russe aurait
été un ornithologue et mother filtreurs
et ça c'est cool
et ça c'est super cool alors après c'est
qu'une annonce c'est qu'une annonce
faite au congrès de la sbp y est mon
collègue victor qui a fait la
présentation victor radar marqueur
a insisté sur le fait que c'était très
préliminaires évidemment donc on va pas
non plus commencer à clamer qu'il y
avait un ordi domino un filtre mais
c'est la direction apparemment dans
laquelle ils vont pour l'instant ce qui
avec chouïa
chouïa ouais ce qui avec le dinosaure de
mongolie chaouia
et les alvarezsauridés de manière
générale vraiment et letairis dinosaures
allonge encore la liste des niches
écologiques que les théropodes ont
conquis un parce que donc les analyses
les alvarezsauridés apparemment c'était
des insectivores m'aider fourmilier quoi
spécialisé dans les dents les insectes
sociaux comme des fourmis lier les
terroriser noz or ils sont herbivores
comme les autres rapts aux orres
les j'ai dit quoi chouïa qui était
insectivores nocturne apparemment est
donc maintenant on aurait une prime à
sorrus qui serait donc il a des grands
yeux donc il serait peut-être nocturne
aussi mais qui en plus les filtreurs
alors là
là on commence à avoir et puis on avait
à ce qu un raptor qui ressemble à un
signe enfin si le spécimen n'est pas un
faux ce qui reste encore ce qui reste
encore débattues bien que bien que les
scientifiques encore une fois du
synchrotron de grenoble qui ont
travaillé dessus soutiennent que il n'y
a pas de signe de que ce soit un faux
salska raptor mais bref si on ajoute en
plus ça c'est ce caractère on a vraiment
une grosse grosse grosse diversité des
théropodes est évidemment spinosaurus le
spinosaurus vie aquatique aussi comme
malika raptor
donc bref
on aurait donc encore on ajouterait
encore un peu plus
à la liste des niches écologiques que
les théropodes ont conquise ont conquis
pardon et donc l'article dont je veux
parler aujourd'hui qui est enfin c'est
pas un article c'est un poster qui a été
présentée la société de paléontologie
des vertébrés et qui vraiment je pense
est le plus important de ce congrès
c'est celui ci réalisée par tomasz carte
au mas carte qui est un grand
paléontologues des théropodes
est qui et qui est donc à explorer la
question 2 est-ce que la paléontologie
amateurs seraient pas un peu en train de
pourrir
est-ce que la paléontologie amateurs
seraient pas un peu en train de pourrir
la paléontologie tout court et donc il
s'est intéressé au cas particulier du
t-rex t-rex qui est une des espèces qui
est commercialement la plus intéressante
donc quand je parle de paléontologie
amateurs j'en reviens à ma définition
qui était la définition que j'ai
utilisée sur la vidéo de
sur le grand jd qui était en gros la
paléontologie amateurs c'est tout ce qui
n'est pas de la paléontologie
professionnelle et la paléontologie
professionnel c'est celle qui est
qui est financé par l'état voilà c'est
là les paléontologues fonctionnaires
quoi donc donc voilà la paléontologie
amateurs dans la paléontologie amateurs
il ya
la jackie et michel
qui vont chercher des fossiles de
dimanche entre deux tournages et lui qui
pose pas tellement problème et il y a
les paléontologues qui cherchent des
fossiles pour la thune pour les revendre
dans la paléontologie amateurs il ya
ceux là aussi et cela ils posent
problème et donc il ya deux grandes
lignes de défense on va dire dans la
paléontologie amateurs il ya la première
qui me fait me taper la tête contre les
murs et qui consiste à dire que
ils font ils font ce qu'ils font parce
que ce sont des passionnés et un cela je
vous dis d'aller vous faire d'aller vous
faire prendre par un t-rex tekken base
de t-rex parce que parce que non
voilà les les paléontologues amateurs
ils ont droit de collecter des fossiles
et de les revendre parce que c'est leur
passion et ils ont droit d'en vivre et
j'ai envie de dire ça sous-entend quand
même assez clairement que les
paléontologues professionnels ne font
pas ça par passion et à ça je n'ai
qu'une chose à dire et c'est un majeur
levé bien haut donc parce que non les
paléontologues professionnels ce que
j'aime pas dans cette explication enfin
ce que j'aime pas dans cette excuse
c'est qu'elle sous-entend clairement que
les professionnels ne sont pas des
passionnés et je suis en train de vous
expliquer ça alors que c'est l'heure de
manger j'enregistre ça c'est l'heure de
manger on est samedi et je vais passer
mon dimanche à faire le montage donc en
gros google des cram et mon repas du
midi est cramé et mon week end est cramé
donc donc vraiment du fond du coeur si
vous êtes du genre à croire que les
paléontologues professionnels ne sont
pas des passionnés
j'ai que ça pour vous voilà
j'ai que ça pour vous la deuxième
excuses maintenant c'est de dire que là
c'est de dire que les la paléontologie
amateurs certes va détruire quelques
fossiles ou va faire perdre par la
revente de certains spécimens va faire
perdre quelques fossiles mais quand même
ils participent beaucoup plus à la
découverte
qu'à la perte donc c'est à dire qu'il y
aurait
contrairement à ma philosophie qui est
de dire avec la revente de fossiles on
sait on sait ce qu'on gagne et on sait
pas ce qu'on perd en gros ça
consisterait à dire l'opposé à savoir
que ce qu'on gagne vaut largement ce
qu'on perd c'est à dire que quand il ya
des beaux spécimens les paléontologues
amateurs les proposent au muséum et puis
ce qui est vendu en fait c'est le menu
fretin quoi c'est à dire les trilobites
ramassés par milliers et pas cher quoi
voilà donc c'est le menu fretin qui
permet de gagner de l'argent les gros
spécimens e scientifiquement intéressant
ils sont proposés aux universités vendus
ou donnés selon les
selon le niveau d'éthique delà du
paléontologue amateur en question voilà
donc il ya ces deux approches et donc la
ligne de défense consiste à dire que
c'est plutôt là
le second cas de figure voilà qui est
plus proéminent à savoir que les beaux
spécimens sont proposés à des fins
scientifiques sont gardés à des fins
scientifiques et ses menus fretins qui
est vendu et c'est la quantité qui fait
le bénéfice quoi
sauf que et donc du coup ce que tomasz
car ces permis de tester bas c'est cette
hypothèse justement est ce que dans le
cas de tyrannosaurus rex est ce que
c'est vraiment le menu fretin qui est
revendue mais les beaux spécimens
profite à la science ou bien est-ce que
ce serait pas l' inverse est-ce que les
beaux spécimens nous passe sous le nez
et le menu fretin et finalement il ne
reste que le menu fretin pour les
universités et bien thomas scar donc
s'est proposé de faire un grand
inventaire de tous les spécimens de
tyrannosaurus rex connu alors déjà il ya
une énorme limitation parce que connut
bas ça veut dire qu'il faut les
connaître faut savoir qu'ils sont là
donc donc déjà quand vous parlez de
paléontologie amateurs on n'est pas
forcément au courant de tout ce qui a
déjà il n'y a pas une transparence à
100% sur la sur tout ce qui a été
découvert mais bref donc il a fait un
grand inventaire de tous les spécimens
connu et alors je pense que je vais
juste lire sa discussion et sa
conclusion fin vous traduire sa
discussion et sa conclusion qui je pense
sont absolument effarante voilà donc
premiers éléments de la discussion
si on mettait tous les spécimens
ensemble donc tous les spécimens de
tyrannosaure ensemble et qu'ils étaient
tous transférés dans des institutions
publiques public trust c'est les
institutions publiques alors
l'échantillonnage passerait de 54
spécimens connu à 100 enfin 54 spécimen
accessible aux scientifiques à 109
donc c'est ce que vous ce qui vous est
représentée là donc cinquante cinq
spécimens chez chez des privés
ouais cinquante cinq spécimens chez des
privés cinquante quatre spécimens dans
le domaine public donc il ya moins bon
il ya un spécimen de moins dans le
public que dans le privé ça fait quand
même ça fait quand même du 50 50 c'est
la moitié de ce qu'on se connaît de
tyrannosaurus est détenu par des privés
voilà et là il dit
scientifique la veille les bols donc
accessible aux scientifiques donc s'il
dit accessible aux scientifiques ça veut
dire que donc dans les collections
commercial les spécimens sont pas
accessibles ils sont perdus pour la
science
les collections publiques ne bénéficient
pas de des du commerce de tyrannosaurus
rex car la plupart sont dans des
collections privées donc dans des
dans des collections privées ou dans des
stocks room c'est à dire qu'ils sont en
stock dans des gros instituts voilà aux
etats unis ils ont ça des gros instituts
comme le black hills institute qui ont d
énormes hangar rempli de dinosaures et
qui attendent d'être vendus et les
scientifiques n'ont pas le droit de les
voir ou non pas le droit du moins ils
ont droit de les voir parce que souvent
ils requièrent l expertise de
scientifiques pour mieux les vendre donc
ils n'ont pas le droit de les voir ils
ont droit de les voir mais ils n'ont pas
le droit de les étudier parce
qu'évidemment c'est pas dans une
institution publique donc on n'a pas
droit de les étudier si c'est pas dans
une institution publique
la valeur les collections commercial ne
font que s'accroître dans les
collections privées
donc les collections privées
s'agrandissent au détriment des
collections publiques c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui on est à 55 on est sur un 50
50 cette proportion a priori à la
tendance à augmenter en faveur des
collections privées ce qui veut dire que
dans le futur on doit s'attendre à ce
que la plupart des tyrannosaures connu
soit dans des mains de collections
privées ce soit dans des mains privées
et non accessible à la science donc dans
le futur il y aura probablement de plus
en plus de t-rex de beaux spécimens de
t-rex dans des mains de collectionneurs
privés
conclusion numéro 4 là enfin
observations numéro 4 par dont on n'est
pas encore aux conclusions
les institutions publiques ne peuvent
pas toujours alors il dit toujours mais
ne peuvent pas ne peuvent plus je veux
dire quand vous voyez les prix en
millions de dollars des derniers t-rex
on peut plus
à l'époque dessus où on pouvait encore
aujourd'hui la fin à l'époque de suez
avant on pouvait mais alors là
aujourd'hui avec des 30 sein des 32
millions de dollars et les machins ont
tous pu ça a été d'ailleurs démontré
encore une fois en face à l'italie
d'ailleurs illustré par dont encore une
fois avec le tricératops qui a été
vendue il ya pas longtemps aux enchères
des sommes colossales je me rappelle
même plus la somme tellement de toute
façon il ya trop de zéro pour pour être
concevable par un esprit humain sain
d'esprit quoi
c'est à dire les institutions publiques
ne peuvent plus suivre c'est à dire que
même si un collectionneur trouve enfin
non pardon même si une institution
privée
trouve un fossile dans l'intention de le
vendre à un institut public
c'est-à-dire trouve un fossile important
et se dit celui-là je vais le vendre au
public au domaine public parce que c'est
un spécimen scientifiquement important
le marché a de toute façon atteint des
sommes beaucoup trop colossal pour qu'
aucune institution publique depuis se
l'offrir de toute façon même si le
collectionneur même si le collecteur
pardon chaque fois c'est collector en
fait que j'essaie de dire au lieu de
collectionneurs mais collector c'est pas
un mot français
même si le paléontologue amateur
qu'il faut que je dise même si le
paléontologue amateur veut vendre son
spécimen à une institution publique et
bien le prix du marché le rang de toute
façon inaccessibles à une institution
publique il ya de moins en moins
d'argent dans la recherche
et les fossiles sont de plus en plus
cher
[Musique]
observation numéro 5
les
l'exploitation commerciale des t-rex se
concentre surtout sur l'est plus alors
les plus grands dépôts de l'aele creek
formation enfin les meilleurs
affleurements de l'aele creek formation
la formation elle creek ce qui veut dire
que et bien l'exploitation commerciale
se concentre surtout là où c'est facile
ne laissant aux paléontologues
professionnelle que les endroits à chier
pour aller chercher des fossiles et
c'est même plus vicieux que ça c'est
même un poil plus vicieux que ça je
pense qu'il va pas aussi suffisamment -
là c'est que non seulement donc
l'exploitation commerciale se concentre
sur les endroits où les fossiles sont
faciles d'accès laissant les endroits à
chier pour les paléontologues
professionnelle mais en plus
il faut voir que il faut avoir
l'autorisation du fermier parce que
évidemment et comme c'est un système qui
est assez proche du système sud africain
en amérique du nord c'est peut-être
linverse c'est qu'en fait les la plupart
des terrains sont appartiennent à des
grandes fermes
et les fermiers les propriétaires
terriens
doivent donner leur autorisation
évidemment pour pour que pour que les
gens puissent déterrer des fossiles
alors la plupart du temps on s'arrange à
l'amiable 1 je veux dire bonjour je peux
venir collecter les fossiles oui ma vie
tu te plaise voilà quand il s'agit d'un
tyrannosaure complet
le fermier il n'est pas dupe
il sait qu'il ya de la moule à à la clé
la baume ou là
il va pas vous laisser rentrer gratos le
mec non non c'est ça se voit bien si
vous avez regardé dino hunter une série
discovery channel que je ne recommande
absolument pas un jeu d'hier ne regardez
pas ça ce n'est pas ça la paléontologie
mais si vous avez regardé la série
d'innovateur l'aspect financier l'aspect
financier pécunier de la paléontologie
amateurs y est alors il est représenté
de façon un peu trop
joli mais il y est bien représentée
c'est représenter du genre ah oui mais
on fait de l'argent pour préserver notre
pour préserver notre notre art de vivre
cesse et des cow boys qui explique
qu'ils préservent leur art de vivre en
chevauchant des quads au grand galop
bref donc mais ne regardez pas dit non
enter mais si vous l'avez vu dinh hoa
hunter ou dinosaur hunter
vous savez quoi je parle voilà et c'est
et du coup le sait ce qui s'est passé
avec suez ou par exemple avec sioux
quand ils ont déterré sioux ils ont payé
le fermier un truc comme marc chaput six
étaient 5000 ou 15000 dollars mais enfin
quand vous savez que si ou a été vendue
pour quand vous regardez là le chiffre 6
ou a été vendue pour quasiment 15
millions de dollars
le fermier c'est un peu sentis floués
quoi
alors qu il manquait quelques zéros à
son chèque ce qui me semble naturel
donc évidemment il ya eu tout un
imbroglio juridique autour de ça entre
autres imbroglios juridiques d'ailleurs
mais bref le faire mais évidemment il a
dit non mais attends le 15 mille dollars
alors que le spécimen en vo 15 millions
d'aidants du ca va le profit là ça va
donc évidemment le si tu dis bonjour
monsieur le fermier je voudrais accéder
à votre ferme parce qu'on ira faut
trouver un fossile le mec qui va
demander quel faux cils
tyrannosaurus rex 1 kw à inclure us
bombe à partir du moment où il a entendu
t-rex le mec il va te demander un chèque
avec plein de zéros et le problème c'est
que ce chèque avec plein de zéros qui
sait qu'il la bassée par les universités
c'est pas les musées et les musées
peuvent pas avancer des millions de
dollars même des milliers je veux dire
enfin je veux dire j'imagine moi un jour
si on trouve un squelette de gorgone
obtient dans le karoo avec le fermier
nous demande de payer 5000 $ us
et bâtons fossiles tu va le garder
parce que parce qu'avec la quantité de
choses que je peux faire à l'université
avec 5000 $ us 5000 $ us ici c'est un
étudiant c'est un étudiant honors
non un étudiant au nord ouest six aces à
5000 $ us way c'est je peux payer un
étudiant au north pendant un an avec ça
je vais pas déterrer un gorgone obtient
avec ça
c'est savoir de question je dirai donc
bref et ça c'est dans la mesure où c'est
pas quinze mille dollars us 1 parce que
quinze mille dollars us lacets festival
du slip là j'ai deux étudiants en thèse
est tous à
15 mille dollars us bref
tout ça pour dire que le
le système public ne peut pas se
permettre de balancer autant d'argent
dans l'hypothèse qu'un beau spécimen
soit dans le sol d'une ferme alors que
le specis alors que le commerce les
instituts privés elles peuvent se le
permettre voilà voilà et ça ça c'est une
réalité qui je trouve n'est pas assez
mise en avant au niveau de ce point
numéro 5 point numéro 6
6 à wil et juvénile les juvéniles on
passerait de 13 spécimens juvéniles à
23,6 les collections privées étaient
ajoutés aux collections publiques
je rappelle l'énorme débat sur l'anneau
tyrannus l'énorme débat on ne sait pas
enfin maintenant on a une assez bonne
idée de nano tyrannus était juste un
juvénile de t-rex mais la raison pour
laquelle le débat sur un anneau tyrannus
est il un juvénile de t-rex ou pas
existe
la raison de l'existence de ce débat
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas assez de
spécimens de tyrannosaurus juvénile il y
en a plus de la moitié dans près de la
moitié pardon qui sont dans des
collections privées de ces tyrannosaure
juvénile voilà on passerait de 13 à 23
spécimens si on ajoutait les les
tyrannosaures juvénile et ça c'est quand
les tyrannosaurus rex d'ailleurs
juvénile un pas seulement pas tous les
autres espèces parce que là en plus on
s'intéresse qu'à une espèce s'intéresse
que à tyrannosaurus rex donc ses aises
c'est ahurissant je trouve ça ahurissant
de
ces fous donc la conclusion
l'exploitation commerciale de t-rex nous
prive donc nous les paléontologues
professionnels ce qui généreront de la
connaissance à partir des fossiles que
nous collectons qui sont collectés ce
qui génère de la connaissance partager
au plus grand nombre
et qui sommes passionnés aussi
[Musique]
rires nerveux
donc là l'exploitation commerciale de
t-rex nous prive de la moitié des
tyrannosaures connus
dont les juvéniles donc une bonne moitié
des spécimens juvéniles connus ou point
numéro 2 point numéro 3 le marché des
fossiles ne facilite pas du tout la
science enfin n'aide pas du tout la
science dont vous voyez le fameux
argument dubawi mais le sait la partie
émergée de l'iceberg tout ça tout ça
ben voilà ça sent dans sa tente à se
confirmer de ce qu'on voit circuler
ce sur quoi on arrive à avoir un
contrôle ce qu'on peut arriver à acheter
sur le marché mais en fait c'est juste
la partie émergée de l'iceberg
on perd énormément on perd énormément en
tout cas quand il s'agit de
tyrannosaurus rex voilà après c'est en
amérique du nord sur tyrannosaurus rex
la ja ja comment dire l'exploitation
commerciale de tyrannosaurus rex empêche
le progrès scientifique notamment à
cause des juvéniles
les institutions publiques ne peuvent
pas acheter les t-rex de les fossiles de
tien ex donc le marché du fossile de
t-rex fait du mal
à la science quoi ça on ne peut plus il
n'y a plus moyen de y'a pas moyen de
suivre en fait les cours du marché des
faux sites de t-rex
et du coup ces spécimens sont perdus
voilà ils sont perdus à moins que le
généreux acheteurs qui a claqué je ne
sais pas combien de millions
est la bonne idée d'en faire don ensuite
à une institution publique je vous
rappelle que c'est pas possible
ethiquement par un an
éthiquement parlant ce n'est pas
possible d'aller étudier un fossile dans
le salon d'un acheteur privé c'est pas
possible
et à chaque fois et est encore une fois
même si on était capable de se payer
même si l'as la recherche
paléontologique étaient capables de se
payer des fossiles à 35 millions de
dollars
même si on avait cet argent bah on
financerait le pillage en achetant ces
spécimens c'est pour ça que la dernière
fois j'avais mis de la nuance aussi sur
l'achat de l'or c'était le bébé t-rex
enfin juvénile t-rex en train de se
battre avec un juvénile tricératops les
dueling dinosaures et tout le monde se
réjouissait voilà il ya spécimens ce
spécimen a été acheté par une
institution publique way cette
institution publique vient d'injecter
des millions de dollars dans le pillage
et ses millions de dollars vont être
utilisés à déterrer on sait pas quoi qui
va finir on sait pas où
est seul on sait pas quoi qui va finir
on sait pas où bas ce sera peut-être un
spécimen 20 fois plus important que
celui quand on vient de gâcher l'argent
du contribuable voilà
qu est ce qu il yad autres il ya aussi
encore une dimension qu'il faut
considérer à propos du pillage c'est que
non seulement on finance du coup le
pillage donc on l'encouragent mais en
plus on montre au reste du monde à
chaque fois qu'il ya à chaque fois comme
ce tricératops vendu des millions et
comme le t-rex vendus stan vendu 35
millions là à chaque fois qu'il ya un
dinosaure comme ça qui est vendu super
cher vous envoyer un énorme signal au
monde sait les états unis qui envoient
un énorme signal au monde en disant hé
regardez il ya de la thune à se faire de
la thune à ce faire en allant piller les
fossiles donc ce n'est pas un problème
américano américain en plus c'est pas du
tout un problème américano américain
tout à l'heure je disais c'est basé sur
les données de t-rex en amérique du nord
mais en réalité c'est pas un problème
américano américains même moi je me
contredis la
selas et les américains qui nous montre
et regardez il ya un max de moulins à se
faire un max de moulins à se faire aller
déterrer des trucs et wendel et des
millions et ça c'est des répercussions
qu'on a même jusqu'ici 1 en afrique du
sud inquiète que ça tombe pas dans
l'oreille d'un sourd un que les fossiles
is vendre des millions ils en ont rien à
faire que ce soit 1,10 hinault dont tout
un machin la toile j'ai pour eux c'est
des dinosaures de toute façon
donc je dirais qu'ils en ont rien à
faire que ce soit des dix innovantes des
gorgones obtient des parts et azor der
s'en fout je veux dire à part ces
moments où tu entends la nouvelle que à
10 dont des millions de dollars us pour
acheter un squelette alors qu'on en a
plein dans le jardin la voix battant
inquiète que ça tombe pas dans l'oreille
d'un sourd donc non c'est pas un
problème américaine aux américains je
retire ce que j'ai dit j'aurais terre
totalement ce que j'ai dit et c'est pour
ça donc que ce point numéro 4 que j'ai
mal traduits du coup c'est should not by
les institutions publiques ne devrait
pas acheter des fossiles de t-rex sur le
marché
et encore moins à des prix aussi
exorbitantes et enfin le marché des tirs
ex devrait s'arrêter voilà il faut
légiférer je pense que sa conclusion
c'est globalement il faut légiférer
contre contre l'exploitation commerciale
de t-rex ce qui à mon avis n'arrivera
pas tout de suite mais bon ça c'est une
opinion personnelle ça il ya des
problèmes dans le fait d'exploiter les
fossiles pour les revendre encore une
fois je sais que ce que je critique là
c'est pas la paléontologie amateurs de
jacky et jacquot qui vont chercher des
fossiles de dimanche comme ça qu'ils
vont les mettre sur leur bon même si ça
aussi dans l'absolu ce sera ça pourrait
être aussi considéré comme problématique
mais c'est pas ça le problème le
problème c'est la vente de faux cils la
vente de faux cils qui conduit à une
course
à aux plus beaux spécimens voilà et du
coup qui prive finalement les la science
des spécimens les plus les plus
importants quoi donc c'est ça qui est
critiqué ici c'est vraiment l'aspect
commercial de la paléontologie amateur
et pas l'aspect l'aspect purement
passionnés quoi si vous collectionnez
des fossiles comme ça pour vous même et
puis quand vous en trouver un qui al air
rares ou précieux ou scientifiquement
important vous contacter les autorités
compétentes savoir à votre université la
plus proche
bah l'absolu il n'y a pas de dans
l'absolu moi en tout cas j'ai pas de
problème avec ça
mais voilà c'est bien ça qu'il faut
préciser je fais pas un énorme plaidoyer
ici contre la paléontologie à matin en
général c'est l'utilisation commerciale
des fossiles qui est problématique l
utilisation et du coup là chiffres à
l'appui il y as démonstration que cette
exploitation commerciale des fossiles
fait plus de mal qu'elle ne fait du bien
voilà ce qui répond à la question de
base est ce que l'exploitation
commerciale
ne produirait pas plus de recherche
qu'elle n'en consomme la réponse dans le
cas de tyrannosaurus rex est non elle ne
produit pas plus de recherche qu'elle
n'en consomme elle consomme pour
l'instant un bon 50 % des spécimens
scientifiquement intéressant et c'est
comme il le dit une tendance qui a
tendance à a tendance à s'accroître
c'est une portion qui a tendance à
s'accroître donc dans un futur proche il
est probable que la majorité des
spécimens scientifiquement intéressante
tyrannosaurus rex soit dans des
collections privées
on reste dans les dinosaures avec cette
étude encore une fois d'un certificat
report étude d'un nouveau spécimen de
petites aventures ni de chinois donc
petit petit oiseau chinois et alors ce
spécimen il est très très beau il s'agit
d'un petit bec un petit bec d'oiseau
chinois avec des dents regardez là comme
elles sont magnifiques cédant veut dire
elles sont bien développés et du coup
ils les ont ils ont scanné le spécimen
est alors ils ont vu des dents mais en
plus ils ont vu des dents de
remplacement et s'aidant de remplacement
elles sont situées comme chez les
dinosaures quoi donc il y avait le même
type de remplacement dentaire chez cet
oiseau que chez les dinosaures
théropodes et du coup ça les conduit à
faire des hypothèses sur comment au
final les les oiseaux ont perdu leurs
dents alors c'est probablement un
ralentissement du remplacement qui a
fini par
conduire à une dégénérescence total de
la dentition en tout cas c'est vraiment
un spécimen qui est très très beau je
trouve qu'il est magnifique le ska les
magnifiques le spécimen est vraiment
très clair enfin je le dire il ya pas de
doute sur le fait que par madame kouassi
vous voyez le même le petit début de bec
la regarder la forme il ya le début de
la forme d'un bec
avec les petites perforations qui
indique qu'ils avaient probablement de
la kératine là toutes ces petites perles
foration neurovasculaire la cia vais
probablement de la kératine ici vous
voyez les narines ici qui sont qui sont
rétractés donc pour laisser la place
justement bec de kératine mais en plus
vous avez les dents moi je trouve ça
magnifique c'est magnifique comme
spécimens c'est beau c'est beau j'espère
qu'il n'a pas été acquis légalement
voilà on continue toujours avec des
dinosaures mais cette fois on sort des
théropodes et on se dirige vers les
sauropodes le sauropodes musso musso
russe
musso russe patagonie cus de son petit
nom donc luce aux russes d'amérique du
sud de patagonie dont on a découvert
quantité 9 et quantités notamment de
juvéniles et en fait ils font
l'hypothèse à partir de cela que et bien
c'est musso russes revenaient
régulièrement sur leurs sites de ponte
alors vous voyez là la coupes
stratigraphiques que vous voyez toutes
les fois ici tic tic en bleu là où ils
sont revenus pondre au même endroit donc
c'est très très intéressant et en plus
donc c'est contrairement au sud de la
france où on a aussi ça dans le sud de
la france en provence on a aussi des
pontes de dinosaures qui sont sur
plusieurs niveaux stratigraphique qui
montrent que les dinosaures revenait n'a
sauf que là ce qui le rend plus c'est
les ossements donc ils ont les ossements
des bébés musso russes qui ont été
observés par par scanner et je crois que
c'est encore une fois nos chercheurs de
grenoble oui vincent fernandez voilà des
chercheurs de grenoble qui ont scanné ça
au synchrotron
et qui ont reconstitué vous voyez le
crâne enfin le squelette d'un de ces
embryons à l'intérieur de son oeuf que
vous voyez ici c'est très très beau
envoyer leurs brillants et les ans
brillant il était vraiment très petit
comparé aux adultes à l'embryon y tient
dans l'oeil de l'adulte voyez ci voulant
rouler là comme il devait l'être dans
son oeuf l'embryon il tient dans l'oeil
de l'adulte alors vous imaginez le type
de croissance explosive que c'est machin
devait avoir c'est assez impressionnant
et donc vous avez à la fois des embryons
mais vous avez aussi des assemblages de
juvéniles qui ont été retrouvés tous
ensemble et ses assemblages de juvéniles
ça veut dire que non seulement les est
close et tous ensemble mais que
contrairement aux tortues qui on savait
les tortues qu elles font exactement ça
elles reviennent pondre au même endroit
chaque année mais après les parents ne
restent pas ils s'en vont et quand les
quand les tortues est close et bellecour
vers la mer enfin un court aussi
rapidement qu'une tortue puisse courir
évidemment
elles se dirigent vers la mer et à se
disperse quoi en mode dispersion de
l'extrême c'est ça qui les protègent au
final c'est le nombre et la dispersion
bon ben là c'est parce que faisait musso
zaurus musso russe pardon musso russe
apparemment ils éclosent m et après ils
restaient ensemble et donc vous avez ces
assemblages de juvéniles qui ont été
retrouvés tous ensemble sur le même site
que les sites de ponte ce qui veut dire
que il y avait une certaine forme de
socialité entre c'est donc non seulement
la l'éclosion et est synchronisé mais
après il y avait social socialité entre
au moins les juvéniles donc ça ça va ça
va de concert avec du coup là
l'idée générale que les sauropodes
étaient des dinosaures plutôt grégaire
enfin après tout les sauropodes n'était
pas forcément grégaire et là de toute
façon ce ne sont pas des sauropodes ce
sont des sauropodomorphes non sauropodes
ça c'est ce qu'on appelait autrefois les
pros ce repas de voiliers qui sont
bipèdes ils n'ont pas un coup aussi long
que les que les brachiosaures et les
diplodocus et vous voyez qu'ils sont
bipèdes ils sont pas encore quadrupèdes
donc ce sont des
sauropodomorphes encore relativement
primitif de ce point de vue là donc
voilà mais ça veut dire que du coup le
l'évolution d'un système social de
socialisation de d'un mode de vie
grégaire voilà c'est ce qu'ils utilisent
un gregario un mode de vie grégaire est
apparue très tôt parce que musso russe
donc et impro sauropodes relativement
basale et il vient du début du
jurassique donc on est bien avant l'ère
des géants du milieu et de la fin du
jurassique donc voilà ça c'est quand
même vachement intéressant et ça et ça
arrive donc été publiés l'enseignante y
fit les portes ça a été vendu
assez honnêtement je crois
sous la forme que les sauropodomorphes
enfin les trop se reposer tu es et tu es
sociaux ce qui est pas la conclusion
principale je veux dire la conclusion
principale ça reste quand même qu'il y
avait une fidélité aux sites de ponte
c'est tout ça la conclusion principale
mais la socialie disons que l'inférence
du d'un mode de vie grégaire et pas loin
derrière eh bien on continue avec les
mammifères prix firmes et les éléphants
les éléphants alors c'est pas c'est pas
du tout un article de paléontologie
c'est paru dans science
et c'est un article qui parle de
l'évolution des défenses chez les
éléphants d'afrique
en réponse à la
pression de sélection imposés par les
braconniers donc voilà les braconniers à
force de chasser les éléphants qui ont
les plus grosses défenses et bien il
impose une pression de sélection
naturelle pour le coup c'est une
sélection naturelle c'est pas voulu par
les braconniers donc c'est une sélection
naturelle il impose une pression de
sélection il élimine en fait de la
population les gènes qui produisent des
éléphants à grande défense et donc ça
c'est un phénomène qui a été observé
depuis longtemps cessé alors c'est pas
totalement avérée parce que les
éléphants c'est quand même une espèce
qui a tant de générations très très long
donc déjà les gens sont un peu
sceptiques sur est ce qu'on peut
vraiment arriver à faire ça en si peu de
temps et de deux légers puis 2 2 c'est
pas sûr est ce qu'on n'a pas juste
éliminé ceux qui avaient les défenses
les plus longues et c'est pour ça que
maintenant on observe que des défenses
courte donc là pour le coup ils se sont
intéressés à la génétique pour aller
voir justement s'il y avait une
signature génétique
dans ces éléphants d'afrique qui indique
qu'il ya eu sélection naturelle voilà et
donc est ce qu'ils ont trouvé et qui est
très intéressant c'est qu'en fait déjà
il ya que les femelles apparemment qui
va là ils se sont même pas intéressé à
la réduction de la taille des défenses
ils sont juste intéressé à la perte au
total des défenses et apparemment il ya
que les femelles qui ont une perte
totale des défenses et ça c'est un
phénomène intéressant parce que vu que
s'il ya que les femelles qui ont une
perte totale des défenses ça veut dire
que selon un
et c'était une hypothèse raisonnable en
génétique s'il ya que les femelles qui
sont affectés par un
par un phénotype ça veut dire que le
même phénomène chez les mâles est en
fait létale ça veut dire que la mutation
qui déclenche ce phénotype chez les
femelles
ne peut pas déclencher ce fait le type
chez les mâles parce que ça les tu en es
du coup s'il ya une différence génétique
entre mâles et femelles qui se reflète à
ce point là ça veut dire que le gène est
localisée sur les chromosomes sexuels
et du coup qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
pour localiser le ou les gènes qui sont
responsables de la perte des défenses
chez les femelles ils ont regardé du
coup sur les chromosomes sexuels et ils
ont cherché les gènes qui spécifiquement
son ont des mutations allélique qui sont
les talent chez les mâles
c'est brillant je trouve ça brillant je
suis sûr que je fais pas assez justice à
la façon dont on sait à quel point ces
brillants quoi c'est brillant c'est à
dire qu'ils ont observé un phénotype
chez les éléphants voilà il observe un
phénotype chez les éléphants les
femelles n'ont pas de défense les mâles
ont toujours des défenses donc la
mutation est localisée sur les
chromosomes sexuels parce que c'est une
différence qui est sexuel et cette
mutation doit être létales pour les mal
parce qu'on l'observé jamais chez les
mâles et du coup on va chercher les
gènes sur le chromosome x pas sur le
chromosome y du coup on s'en fout ça
donc il ya vraiment plus que un
chromosome que tu regardes en réalité ce
qui se passe c'est que la mutation l et
al donc il ya deux allèles unal el kihel
et al il ya au moins deux allèles unal
elle qui est née talent et au moins une
autre qui ne l'est pas et comme les
femelles ont deux chromosomes x
et ben il ya tout il ya au moins une
halle elle qui va compenser l'autre bon
bah sinon si la femelle a les deux
allèles qui sont létale elle est morte
le dire mais comme elle a deux
chromosomes x elle a deux fois plus de
chances de survivre kamal le mal lui il
a que un croc un seul chromosome x
l'autre ça y est le problème c'est que
s'il a la mauvaise copie du gène bas il
est mort voilà c'est tout
voilà donc on cherche un gène qui a au
moins une à l'ale ou un allèle je sais
plus
qui en moins un allèle qui elle étale et
l'autre pas voilà et donc comme les
femelles ont deux chromosomes x du coup
ça fait qu' il ya au moins un allèle qui
peut sauver l'autre si jamais une
femelle est affecté par la mutation
donc alors que des mâles eux ne peuvent
pas s'ils l'ont mauvaise haleine c'est
fini son marc
goua là donc ils ont cherché sa et donc
ils ont comparées aux génomes humains en
fait ils ont juste parce que les
mammifères ils ont tous plus ou moins
les mêmes gènes dont qu'ils ont
comparées aux génomes des autres
mammifères qui connaissent génome humain
a inclus et du coup ils ont repéré une
série de mutations comme ça qui
corresponde à ce génotype à ce fait nos
types et donc à la fin ils arrivent
quand même à
restreindre à quelques mutations donc
les mutations qui sont listées ici voilà
un mail x
donc je crois quelques deux gènes à la
fin ils arrivent ils arrivent quand même
à isoler deux jeunes femmes hélix et
net one day mais [ __ ] c'est même moi
je trouve ça merveilleux d'arriver à
faire comme ça juste avec de la
puissance statistique de la logique
génétiques et des banques de données en
ligne bam tu arrives à isoler deux gènes
comme ça vim c'est de leur faute à eux
si les éléphants ont pu de défense et
donc il ya bien une mutation et donc il
ya bien une sélection bîmes
voilà parce que c'était ça la question
de base 1 est-ce qu'il ya sélection ou
pas bah on a retrouvé les deux gènes
donc
il ya bien eu une mutation dont il ya
bien une sélection bimbamboom
tak tak badaboum c'est comme ça que tu
as fait c'est beau c'est beau il n'ya
pas d'autre moyen de le décrire c'est
juste beaucoup ensuite on va terminer
avec les invertébrés voilà des petites
curiosités parmi les invertébrés la
première basse et les deuils hyper
composé chez les facs au pid et donc les
les trilobites c'est parmi les
trilobites les plus connus du dévonien
donc les facs copie d
un à l'hyper composé donc ce qui vous
appelle un oeil hyper composer c'est
qu'en gros vous avez l'oeil qui est
composé donc y est comme celui des
mouches à qui est faite de petite
rosselle posées les unes sur les autres
chez les facs au pid et apparemment ce
qu'ils ont mis en avant mais je suis pas
du tout un expert pour juger si c'est
vrai ou pas en gros c'est qu'à
l'intérieur de chaque petite hausse elle
comme celle là eh ben il yad'autres
petite rosselle encore il ya d'autres
petits récepteurs un intérieur du gros
récepteur en groupe donc ça c'est un
oeil hyper composer c'est à dire qu'un
intérieur de chaque lentilles de leurs
composés il ya encore un autre oeil
qu'opposé à l'intérieur et ça c'est
balèze si c'est vrai c'est balèze et
comme ils disent comme ils disent dans
la publication ce il ya que chez les
trilobites qu'on voit ça un hyper
composé donc un oeil composé à
l'intérieur de chaque petit car carreaux
de leurs composés c'est ce fou c'est
prodigieux comme j'ai dit je n'ai pas du
tout les expertises pour juger si c'est
vrai ou pas mais si c'est vrai c'est
prodigieux et donc ça montre encore une
fois que vie ancienne n'est pas
primitive parce que comme ils le disent
un hyper composer c'est unique dans tout
le règne animal là aucune espèce moderne
gaza et n'a jamais eu aucune espèce
fossile autre que les facs copie des
apparemment qu'ils ont eu donc c'est
quand même assez balèze donc anciens
n'est pas forcément primitif c'est la
leçon à retenir
et puis on termine on termine par les
tardigrade
ça tout le monde l'a partagé ce truc là
un fossile de tardigrade du milieu c'est
noah sait trop bien les tardigrade si
vous le savez au moins ce qu'il raconte
cet article
personne personne est capable de me dire
ce qu'il raconte cet article parce que
cet article en fait ils racontent pas
grand chose c'est marrant même
d'ailleurs qu'ils soient publiées dans
dans proceedings of the royal society
parce que proceedings of the royal
society c'est quand même pas le sait
quand même pas un journal pour pécore
c'est du gros journal
c'est pas un journal spécialisé
paléontologie rien que ça arrivé à
publier de la paléontologie dans un
journal qui peut spécialisés pas
spécialisé paléontologie c'est bien
c'est vachement bien c'est une grosse
nouvelle
est le problème enfin je sais pas je
sais pas ce qu'il ya d'intéressant dans
cet article au delà du seul fait que
c'est un tardigrade et que les
tardigrade c'est cool
il ya une espèce de hype autour des
tardigrade la toul et tous les deux
semaines vous avez quelqu'un qui vient
vous postez un truc du genre les tarder
rades survivent dans l'espace alors que
non c'est la forme de résistance des
tardigrade y en a trois qui sont revenus
du vide spatial après 20 minutes quand
même pas la même chose que les
tardigrade survie vers l'espace c'est la
forme de résistance qui résiste au vide
spatial bon
c'est une forme de résistance c'est dans
le nom mais bref donc donc il ya une
espèce de hype comme ça aux tournées
tardigrade est alors apparemment le seul
fait d'avoir tardigrade dans le titre
permet d'être veut permet d'être publiée
dans proceedings by parce que cet
article ne dit absolument rien sur les
tardigrade je veux dire c'est interdit
grade il ressemble à un interdit grade
vous voyez dans la phylogénie il vient
se sait pas où il est c'est quoi son
petit nom
par adorent audi pour 18 parades
euromédis puce je suis fatigué un
parent à dori fort ils eussent part à
dori faurie bus vous voyez dans l'arbre
phylogénétique des tardigrade parade aux
riffs horrible us
vient se glisser confortablement au
milieu d'autres tardigrade moderne voilà
c'est même pas un tardigrade hyper
basale qui se dressent glisser là et qui
nous apprendrait de grandes choses sur
l'évolution des tardigrade non j'ai
interdit grade qui vient se glisser
confortablement dans la phylogénie dans
une famille qui existe toujours
donc sa morphologie nous apprend pas
grand chose de plus que ce qu'on savait
déjà sur les tardigrade encore une fois
je suis pas spécialiste mais enfonce
d'après ce qui est dit dans l'article
j'ai pas l'impression que ça
révolutionne notre connaissance des
tardigrade ya peut-être vrai quelques
crochets en plus qu'ils sont différents
des choses comme ça la grosse conclusion
de l'article laisser raconter dans le
dans le résumé c'est la grosse
conclusion de l'article sais c'est que
peut-être la raison pour laquelle on
trouve pas de tardigrade c'est parce
qu'ils sont tous dans l'ombre
ouais parce qu'il ya que trois fossiles
de tardigrade dans le monde en gros donc
ça c'est le troisième
est donc là peut-être voilà les trois
fossiles de tardigrade y en a 2 du
crétacé de dans l'ordre du crétacé
du new jersey et un dans l'ombre
dominicain c'est celui qui écrit qui est
décrit la voilà il ya trois tardigrade
fossiles alors c'est peut-être juste la
rareté des tardigrade qui fait que ça a
été publié dans un grand journal je sais
pas j'en ai aucune idée mais en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que j'ai pas
l'impression que que ça révolutionne
notre connaissance des tardigrade donc
si c'est juste une curiosité voilà je
trouve ça curieux que les gens soient
aussi intéressé par les tardigrade mais
au final je pense que tous les gens tu
demandes à tous les gens qui ont partagé
la nouvelle loi à tardigrade fossiles du
miocène mais pourquoi c'est intéressant
parce que c'est un tardigrade oui mais
pourquoi c'est intéressant d tardigrade
pas parce qu'ils survivent dans l'espace
oui mais là il est mort dans l'ombre il
est patient vivant dans l'espace
celui-là il ne mord dans l'ombre alors
pourquoi celui-là il est intéressant
parce que le tardigrade tir avoir sur
wikipédia
allez voir dans wikipédia pourquoi les
tardigrade c'est intéressant voilà
c'est juste une curiosité moi je trouve
ça marrant ça m'a demandé aux gens mais
pourquoi c'est intéressant
alors après c'est probablement
intéressant pour un expert des
tardigrade mais du coup pourquoi ces
publié dans une si grosse revue si c'est
intéressant pour un expert s'il faut
être un expert des tardigrade pour
savoir pourquoi c'est intéressant
pourquoi c'est dans proceedings of the
royal society
mais bon c'est pas grave enfin je veux
dire c'est pas grave je ne suis pas
jaloux c'est juste que je trouve ça
curieux que la hype autour des
tardigrade soit tellement immense qu'on
en arrive à publier des articles
sur un tardigrade fossiles du miocène
donc même pas le plus vieux même pas le
plus banal même pas le plus primitif ne
même pas le rien du tout que ce
tardigrade soit publié dans une grosse
revue ça je trouve ça très drôle bref
voilà je n'ai pas les oignons
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi abonnez
vous pour ne rien manquer l'ancien et je
vous dis à très bientôt
bon
[Musique]